oh mein Gott
das Messer ist gebrochen
aha
eine Zeit mit der ich sehr zufrieden bin
und ich glaube dass das alles wirklich
dazu geführt hat dass ich so früh
abgebrochen habe ich bin richtig
glücklich
ich will gar nicht daran denken was noch
alles kommt
ausgesetzt in der Wildnis von Schweden
kämpft ein Mann sieben Tage mit sieben
Gegenständen ums Überleben ich bin
wieder da der erste Versuch endete für
den outdoor-neuling schnell bei uns zu
mir ehrlich übelst live Sport und Helme
waren ihm dadurch sicher doch jetzt ist
er zurück an dem Ort an dem alles begann
die Wiedergutmachung keine Kamera Teams
Jetzt Geht's Ab kein Kontakt zur
Außenwelt raste aus Mann vollkommene
Isolation
herzlich Willkommen zu gay seven
ich habe diesen zwei Versuch so
unendlich lang vor mir hergeschoben weil
ich immer gedacht habe es wäre nicht die
richtige Zeit es würde mir irgendwas
fehlen und eigentlich hätte ich
jederzeit starten können und genauso ist
es mit all den kreativen guten Ideen die
bei euch in den Köpfen rumspielen ihr
müsst einfach nur starten und genau
deswegen bin ich unheimlich stolz das
shopify das heutige Video als Partner
unterstützt shopify ist die perfekte all
in one-lösung um ohne irgendwelche
Programmierkenntnisse und vorher
Erfahrung ein eigenes Business zu
starten und das meine ich wenn ich sage
denn ich habe schon einige Male hier auf
Youtube unter Beweis gestellt nicht nur
ist es durch den website editor
unfassbar leicht einen Job aufzuziehen
nein man kann auch Dich live Analytics
und Statistiken von den Kunden lernen
und so mehr verkauft ich würde sogar
soweit gehen dass ohne shopify die
komplette trader-serie gar nicht möglich
gewesen wäre mein eigener klamotten
online shop die Golfbälle die ich euch
verschenkt habe Porsche Modelle und der
Print on Demand Shop laufen und liefen
alle über shoppy feiern und auch ohne
dass ihr es wisst seid ihr tagtäglich in
Shops unterwegs eure lieblings Brands
und auch meine lieblings Brands nutzen
nämlich zu großen Teilen das Ding ist
ein Shop aufzuziehen lässt sich online
kreativ auszuleben war noch nie so
einfach wie es also klickt auf den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung und
gebt euren Träumen eine Chance ihr habt
ehrlich nichts zu verlieren und dieses
Tool ist der Oberhammer das sage ich aus
voller Überzeugung und als kleines
Dankeschön weil ihr diese Serie so krass
supportet und weil ich Lust hatte noch
mal einen Job zu bauen gibt es in diesem
Video wieder ein verstecktes Passwort zu
einem Shop der auch in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt ist findet
das Passwort tragt es ein und sichert
euch eins der kostenlosen Produkte seid
schnell die Artikel sind begrenzt und
jetzt viel Spaß mit der dritten Folge
meines Selbstversuchs
herzlich willkommen am Tag 4 es geht
genauso weiter wie die letzten Tage Wind
und Regen
ich bleibe liegen bis durch ist
fick mich guten Morgen liebe Sorgen das
Ding hält besser als gedacht und auch
heute Nacht hat es wieder geregnet aber
das hier wirkt alles ziemlich trocken
geil alles in bester Ordnung und wir
starten sofort mit Challenge für Tag
viel ich weiß natürlich alles was kommt
aber ich weiß nicht in welcher
Reihenfolge jetzt heute einen Floß bauen
muss mir Insekten in den Mund stopfe was
hier Sache ist
fire Baby deine Aufgabe mach ein Feuer
mit Hilfe eines feuerbohrers das kann ja
was werden dafür kannst du dir einen
Bogen bauen oder deine Hände benutzen
das Feuer muss einzig und alleine vom
Feuerbohrer stammen schaffst du es ein
Feuer mit mindestens eine Minute
Brenndauer zu entfachen erhältst du
dieses gesamten 7 Punkte Filme die
Minute zu Verifizierung du hast Zeit bis
die Sonne untergeht
ach du scheiße folgender Plan feuerborn
ist unheimlich schwierig das weiß ich
weil Fritz damit seit Jahren immer
wieder kämpft im Nassen Gebieten und so
weiter der hat das hinbekommen aber
fritz ist jemand der jahrelange
Erfahrung hat und die habe ich nicht das
bedeutet ich muss mir möglichst gute
Vorarbeit leisten bedeutet so viel wie
ich mache mir ein Feuer normal mit
meinem Feuerzeug an und trockene am
Feuer
das gesamte Holz dass ich benutzen will
komplett durch nicht so das brennt aber
einfach das ist komplett furztrocken ist
und probiere es dann damit so glaube ich
kann ich die einzige Möglichkeit wie ich
irgendeine Chance habe glücklicherweise
habe ich ja noch paracordt damit kann
ich mir den Bogen spannen und mit dem
Messer kriege ich auch noch Holz
gespalten und ich glaube genau damit
fangen wir an brauchen irgendwas was
wahrscheinlich echt nicht auf dem Boden
liegt sondern ein bisschen vom Boden weg
so was hier in der Sonne
das wirkt auch feucht das ist auch
nichts ist auch noch viel zu schwer ich
weiß um ehrlich zu sein halt auch nicht
wie man das perfekte Holz findet
vielleicht da vorne sowas das sieht aus
als wäre
ja okay das wäre es wirklich weit vom
Boden weg
ja das hier wirkt schon trockener ich
glaube hier von säge ich mir mal ein
Stückchen ab
ja ich komme aus dem Bett denke ich habe
mega Power nicht eine Sekunde irgendwas
und merke ich überhaupt keine Kraft
der könnte trocken sein aber
lieber nicht
ein Pilz warum Pilz komplett nass das
ist auch komplett nass
keine Ahnung Alter
nee das ist komplett nass
oder soll ich das wirklich wagen
dieses Ding
ich meine da oben wird das doch
furztrocken sein oder ich fange mal
langsam an zu sägen und zwar will ich
den am liebsten in die Richtung hauen
das bedeutet ich will den
da Sägen so so sieht das aus wenn man
nicht aus den Fehlern anderer lernt und
ich hoffe jetzt einfach dass nichts
runter kommt
[Musik]
ist noch nicht
ich glaube das ist gut
schön weghalten von mir
noch einmal zurückschwingen lassen jetzt
volle Kraft voraus
[Applaus]
geil sowas in trocken
ist doch
perfekte Auflagefläche Alter ich kann
mir eine Regenrinne bauen hier mit
ich war einfach eine Regenrinne das hier
sieht aus wie der perfekte Boden von
baugrill oh nee das sind irgendwelche
Eier
schnell weg
es ist nur die Frage wie kriege ich das
darüber ich glaube ich schneide das
immer so zwei Meter Stücke
essen oder so
ja ich muss gleich einmal
eine vernünftige Ladung sammeln
oh mein Gott
wie so ein Dulli und die ganzen
Sägespäne gehen verloren und nachher
probiere ich irgendwie händeringend an
Sägespäne zu kommen und dann kriegst
nicht hin deswegen
sage ich Dir jetzt direkt hier in meine
Regenrinne
perfekt kommt gar nichts drin an
kann nicht mehr
jetzt fallen Sägespäne rein
perfekt
für die nächsten Tage
also um ganz ehrlich zu sein
ist heute so der richtig
oder das also ich bin die ganze Zeit ja
einsam und hier ist nichts und niemand
weit und breit
aber heute bin ich wirklich wirklich
viel in Gedanken ich habe echt
kein Bock mehr die Phasen wo ich
wirklich gehypt bin werden immer kürzer
ich merke dass ich immer mehr einfach in
der Hängematte rumsitze nicht mal mehr
die Kamera Anmache einfach Zeit vergehen
lassen und hoffe dass das hier irgendwie
zu einem Ende kommt und ich einfach
keinen Bock mehr auf die scheiß
Isolation habe ich keinen Bock mehr
darauf hab hier zu sein ich kann Bock
mehr habe auf die Challenges ich habe
einfach keinen Bock mehr ich habe keinen
Bock mehr zu sägen ich habe keinen Bock
mehr ans Wasser zu laufen ohne Wasser zu
holen
keinen Bock mehr auf die Mücken ich will
einfach nicht mehr ich will einfach
nicht mehr
hier ist nicht
ist nichts gar nichts ist hier ich fühle
mich dreckig ich fühle mich räudig ich
habe Hunger
ich habe keine Energie
es ist richtiger abfuck aber ich
bin quasi gezwungen
das jetzt dieses Mal durch zu machen
wegen diesem scheiß erst versucht hätte
ich das dadurch gezogen hätten müssen
wir die ganze Scheiße hier nicht mehr
antun aber ein zweites Mal aufzugeben
ist eigentlich keine Option
ich trage die scheiße jetzt rüber machen
wir ein Feuer an trockne das Zeug und
setzt mich ein bisschen ans Feuer
und hoffe dann wird es besser
ich mach die Kamera aus und sage dass
ich keinen Bock mehr habe und es fängt
an zu nieseln
top komm weiter regnen super ist genau
was ich brauche für meine Challenge es
ist zum kotzen zum Kotzen zum kotzen
scheiß aber jetzt glaube ich einfach
durch den Regenjacke habe ich eh gestern
reingepackt wie so ein Idiot
jetzt regnet
meine Fresse Alter
das hier
fuckt mich bis heute
so krank ab
was zum Fick ist das ich will hier
sieben Tage draußen nie was machen und
an Tag 2 geht diese Scheiße kaputt ist
unglaublich Alter und ich dachte ich
kaufe irgendein Qualitätsprodukts
kompletter Müll guck mal den hier habe
ich gerade auf dem Weg gefunden
der ist nicht perfekt gerade aber dieses
Stück hier könnte schon passen als
dass das richtige Material ist aber
das nehme ich einfach mal mit
schauen wir mal
ich muss das an der Klinge packen sonst
kann ich das nicht mehr benutzen
[Musik]
komplett nass
muss ich komplett trocknen das ist der
Grill
keine Ahnung habe ich hier eine Kerbe
rein machen muss oder nicht werden wir
gleich sehen das brauche ich noch einen
Bogen
und ich muss das Feuer anmachen bin hier
wirklich kleinteilig am vorbereiten
um immer nächst größere Stücke Holz zu
haben
die jetzt gleich alle
einzeln
noch getrocknet werden und dann
überlasse ich nichts dem Zufall ich habe
Birkenrinde getrocknet Späne gehobelt
und dann die und dann eben noch
richtiges Holz oder größeres
das hier habe ich gerade eben gefunden
hier so eine Kerbe wo mein Ast drin war
und vielleicht benutze ich das habe ich
mir überlegt
[Applaus]
was richtig nach hart
drecksmesser Alter was für eine
unglaubliche scheiße ich habe die ganze
Zeit geredet ohne das lief ich mache
jetzt erstmal ein normales Feuerchen
damit ich die ganzen anderen Sachen hier
schön Trocknen kann und dann geht die
Party ab so also der Baum an sich ist
schon mal Spitze das brennt
wie Sau oh wunderbar also beim Feuer
wirklich ist die Vorarbeit das A und O
ich habe das hier so schön klein
gespalten und dann geht das mit ein
bisschen Zeug
komplett lichterloh in Flammen auf so
und jetzt lege ich schon mal meine
Sachen daneben zum trocknen
hier diese Kerbe die ich gemacht habe
Balken lege ich so hier hin
dann kann das schön durchtrocknen der
anderen Seite
muss das hier auch dahin
mache ich mir hier einfach noch so ein
und da ist eigentlich nur die Seite
wichtig
jetzt muss ich mir im Auge behalten dass
es auf keinen Fall reinfällt
ich lese mir den Zettel gleich noch mal
durch aber ich habe dem nicht entnehmen
können dass das jetzt nicht okay wäre
schön trockenes Holz braucht man dafür
und ich sorge für trockenes Holz
man sieht
richtig kommt ich hoffe ihr seht das
auch auf der Cam
kommt oder so raus
kommt wie hätte ich denn damit Feuer
machen sollen
niemals boah ich glaube das ist ein
Geniestreich um ehrlich zu sein so das
war jetzt einmal komplett abgekuckt ich
habe das jetzt hier mühevoller
kleinarbeiter wieder abgeschabt damit
ihr auch wieder Material ist das
überhaupt verkokeln kann und jetzt bauen
wir alles zusammen bauen noch einen
Bogen und dann probieren wir es einfach
mal wenn ich das so nicht hinbekomme
dann gar nicht aber ich glaube der Weg
ist gar nicht so dumm
ich habe einen Bogen und die ist richtig
Zug drauf unten habe ich keinen Knoten
drin
ja wunderbar
sondern das einfach so tausendmal hier
drum gewickelt weil ich nicht weiß wie
ich das sonst zu knoten soll wir
probieren es einfach mal aus
erster Versuch
hier ist richtig Spannung drauf
ach du scheiße ich Rutsch komplett aus
der Kerbe ach nee ich glaube ich muss
mir eine neue Kerbe bauen so neues noch
neuer Versuch
mein Gott
Alter das geht aber ab
Alter hier ist gar nichts das ist viel
zu nass das sieht einfach nur
spiegelglatt
ist das falsche Holz es muss das falsche
Holz sein guck mal was hier für speeds
mache Alter
das funktioniert es funktioniert
[Musik]
kein bisschen Glut
Alter
habt ihr das gesehen
und ich sag noch es ist das falsche Holz
ich glaube es ist das falsche Holz aber
vielleicht haben wir so gut
durchgetrocknet dass wir es hinbekommen
Alter
oh mein Gott
kein bisschen Glut Alter
ich muss weiter durchziehen
ach du scheiße das wäre ja so
geisteskrank oh meine Hände tun weh
scheiße
nein das Ding ist ich habe halt keinen
so richtiges Zumba Bett ne
oh nein es fängt an zu regnen
oh nein oh nein oh nein oh mein Gott der
schlechteste Zeitpunkt es ist
unglaublich wirklich man hat ein
Erfolgserlebnis und man wird dann
einfach wieder in den Boden gestampft oh
mein Gott
es ist zum Mäuse melken bevor ich jetzt
wirklich weitermache suche ich mir mehr
zundermaterial ich habe das hier an
diesem Bäumen gefunden ich weiß nicht ob
das wirklich brennt ich teste das jetzt
gleich erstmal mit dem Feuerzeug aber
hiermit könnte ich mir vielleicht so ein
richtiges Nest bauen ich habe zwar
gerade noch keine Gluten bekommen aber
es hat ja schon so gewirkt als wenn ich
das jetzt noch mal länger und
weitermachen würde dass das klappen
könnte also hier raus und Netz bauen und
dann gucken ob das geht
kurzer Test mit dem Feuerzeug es wirkt
schon trocken aber es wirkt irgendwie
nicht so als wird das so krank brennen
oh doch
doch okay perfekt
das Zeug hier jetzt geht's ab jetzt
jetzt geht's ab wenn ich das schaffe das
wäre wirklich geisteskrank okay okay
okay okay
so ich habe mir kurze Hand ein neues
Brett gebaut für oben
oben ist ja eh nicht so wichtig da muss
muss sich nur drehen
mein gott ich hasse es
rutscht ab meine Fresse
mein Gott in der Ruhe liegt die Kraft
ich flippe aus alter
ich war so nah dran gerade eben was für
eine scheiße ich gebe dem jetzt wirklich
noch ein bisschen mehr Seil oh was für
eine Pizza Alter
weil ich einfach mal auf schnell auf
hektisch vielleicht ist das so rein um
das da rein
hilft nicht Müll
so eine Pizza Alter es warum kriege ich
das jetzt nicht mehr hin
ich raste aus alter ich raste aus was
für eine was für ein räudiger Müll es
ist unglaublich dieser Müll dieser
unglaubliche Müll ich flippe wirklich
gleich
komplett aus
es ist zu Hause jetzt ist es zu Hause
jetzt ist es zu Hause
es wäre so krank wenn ich das
hinbekommen würde erstes Mal in meinem
Leben dass ich machen würde das
allererste Mal
ich
werde verrückt
raste aus Mann
wie konnte da gerade eben kein einziger
verfickter Funke sein jetzt habe ich
hier den übelsten Zunder und jetzt
kriege ich das Ding nicht eine Umdrehung
mehr gedreht
nein
hey ich lasse es sein ich lasse es ich
pack die Sachen wieder weg reg mich kurz
ab und ich werde das versuchen bis in
den Sonnenuntergang aber es geht nicht
so es ist soweit ich bin ich bin
komplett abgenervt
ich laufe jetzt eine Runde einmal
komplett um den Teich und guck ob ich
irgendwas finden kann was mir hilft eine
Flasche werde absolute Traum das ist
nicht immer wieder mein Kopf da ins
Wasser stecken muss um ein paar Schlücke
zu trinken und auch mal Wasser mit ins
Camp nehmen kann weil jetzt gerade laufe
ich immer darüber trink trink trink
trink trink dann mache ich irgendwas geh
zurück ins Camp
streng mich nur ein bisschen an und dann
muss ich wieder darüber laufen ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass hier vorne
was angespielt wird weil das werdet ihr
gleich sehen die Wellen kommen immer
genau aus der Richtung
oder vielleicht ganz vorne auf der Zunge
wo ich in Staffel 1
ausgesetzt wurde da war beim letzten Mal
ja auch schon
wie so ein Feuerplatz von irgendwelchen
Kanuten oder so die alle sieben
Pfingsten mal hier vorbeikommen
und hoffentlich sind die wenig
umweltbewusst und haben vielleicht
irgendwas liegen lassen oder so
seht ihr die Welt kommen immer hier so
an also im Zweifelsfall wird hier
irgendwann irgendwas angespült
ja
und jetzt heißt es suchen
schon schön
wirklich schön würde ich meinen Camp
noch mal bauen würde ich wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen näher ans Wasser bauen
hier ist nichts
Federn Federn also wenn ich wirklich
irgendwas mit Federn bauen will dann
gibt sie hier genug
nichts
gar nichts da
ist was
irgendeine
aber kein Haken oder soll es ja keine
kein fischergarden keine Angelschnur
aber das wäre es natürlich
hier wären die Barsche
wenn ich mich recht entsinne guck mal
hier ist auch wieder überall scheiße was
ist das wohl ist das für ein Tier Alter
guck mal hier ist überall Kacke
gar nichts ist hier
hier ist Müll den nehme ich mit
sogar frisch das mindest
Haltbarkeitsdatum
31.10 20 23 oh was würde ich für so ein
bisschen Angelschnur und einen Haken
geben Alter
ja
herzlich willkommen soweit ich mich
erinnern kann an meinem ersten Spot
hier ist der Draht den ich damals
gefunden habe nehme ich auf jeden Fall
mit
weil sie aber nicht wofür ich den
gebrauchen könnte
aber die hier sind doch nicht von mir
oder die habe ich doch niemals um
gemacht
nach zwei Jahren würden die doch nicht
so aussehen oder
nee es kann eigentlich nicht sein aber
ich glaube trotzdem dass das hier der
Spot war krass
komplett offen ihr merkt man auch wie
viel Wind hier durchkommt Hammer dumm
na ja
und es kommt Pilze
aber noch keinen einzigen großen gesehen
wie schön sieht das aus
richtig krass
ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr Tag
4 dann Nachmittag ich habe das mit dem
Feuer versucht ich kriege es nicht hin
es nervt mich ab ich versuche es wieder
es klappt nicht versucht es wieder es
klappt nicht ich versuche jetzt gleich
noch mal aber abseits davon hat man so
unendlich viel Zeit das ist wirklich
unglaublich wie viel Zeit man hat ich
sitze hier rum und Stahl Löcher in die
Luft ich habe jetzt hier alles gemacht
ich habe angefangen die Stöcke an dem
Baum zu zählen ich habe also nachgedacht
und nachgedacht über tausende Dinge aber
ich es fühlt sich an als hätte ich genug
nachgedacht ich will nicht mehr nur mit
mir alleine sein ich will wieder mit
Leuten reden ich will Reaktionen auf
irgendwas bekommen das ist der absolute
Horror wirklich das ist ich kann mir
gerade jetzt im Moment nichts
schlimmeres vorstellen ich habe einfach
keinen Bock mehr und ich will dass es
vorbei geht hätte ich jetzt noch mal die
Wahl hätte ich garantiert ein angelset
mitgenommen dann hätte man sich
hinstellen können und hätte warten
können aber im Zweifelsfall wäre
irgendwann irgendwas passiert das ist so
ein nicht grundloses warten und man kann
jetzt auch nicht anfangen hier joggen zu
gehen oder Bahn zu schwimmen oder
irgendwas zu machen weil man die Energie
dazu nicht hat das ist echt richtige
Größe Scheiße vor dem Herrn wirklich
und mir geht's ja noch gut ich habe
meinen Tag ich habe meine Hängematte ich
habe meinen Schlafsack mir ist nicht
kalt
aber es ist fucking langweilig
so noch mal ich sage es euch das wird
jetzt das letzte Mal sein dass ich diese
Scheiße Versuche
von letzte Mal
ich warum springe ich mache jetzt hier
eine coole rein
es geht kaputt
mehr ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
so ich habe mich jetzt erzählt ein
kleines Feuer zu machen mit dem einzigen
Sinn und Zweck die Überbleibsel dieser
drecks Challenge
loszuwerden und jetzt verbrenne ich
alles davon weil anders hat die ganze
Scheiße das nicht verdient ich hasse es
ich hasse diesen Tag das war der
beschissenste Tag den ich bisher gehabt
hatte ich weiß nicht mehr was ich machen
soll Alter es nervt mich nur noch ab ich
es ist wirklich zum Heulen von außen
wirkt das vielleicht so ein bisschen
lächerlich aber ich will wirklich
einfach losfliehen dass mich ab nervt
weil es Pisse ist und weil ich das hasse
guck mal das hätte wäre ein Funke
gewesen ein Funke und das Ding brennt
lichterloh es hätte so einfach sein
können
aber wir schließen ab damit
so jedes Stück einzeln hier
dieses scheiß Ding der Scheiß Bora
geh in Flammen auf du Stück Scheiße
[Musik]
ich gehe mir jetzt mal meinen
Abendbrot zusammen suchen
erstaunlicherweise gibt es Blaubeeren
in der Staffel 1 schon tausendmal
gesehen
und schaut euch das an die sind die
Verein ich habe halt nach wie vor keinen
Behältnis das bedeutet ich sammeln die
immer in meiner Hand ist so eine halbe
Hand voll ab und dann mache ich einen
großen wissen
1 2 3
so aber erstaunlicherweise geht mir das
nicht auf den Sack also der Geschmack
ich glaube es liegt daran dass ich
einfach Hunger habe und egal was nehme
so und mit leichtem Regen und wieder in
der Hängematte
endet Tag Nummer 4 und ich freue mich
riesig Augen zu Morgen aufwachen und
über dem Berg sein dann geht es nur noch
Richtung Ziel die sieben Tage und nach
wie vor ist mein Tab dicht alles ist
wunderbar
und ich
mache jetzt die Äuglein zu Gute Nacht
tschüss
aus
ich bin ein Star aber Holt mich hier
raus